now there are some customers who are
paying
slack a lot of money there are 87
customers paying over 1 million dollars
a year to use slack
and that has been growing so those are
the big fish those are the whales in the
system
i think that's where benioff sees that
he has an opportunity
maybe there's another 500 customers who
will spend a million dollars a year
maybe there's more than that maybe
there's a thousand customers and you
know what if anybody knows who those
customers are
it's bending off and salesforce because
they
know who's got big huge sales teams they
know who's using their crm systems they
know who's using tableau
they already have them as customers and
they can just look at that list of let's
say the top 500
salesforce customers and look at the top
500
list at slack and i bet you when they
looked at those two lists
they said wow slack is not into these
large organizations yet
we have an opportunity to help them and
accelerate
and grow that 87 people spending a
million dollars a year on the product
maybe we can make it 870 right at a zero
and that would be a thesis that could
work revenue
was up 50 year over year so that is a
high growth company
and you if you look at um how they grew
they they grew to 200 million for the
for q1
uh 215 million which is up 49 year over
year and obviously that's only 7
quarter over quarter they're up to 130
000 total paid customers so i think that
they're
very popular amongst smaller companies
but not the big companies
and they're not as predatory like if you
look at the pricing of slack they only
charge you for people who use the
product
they've kind of got some interesting not
cutthroat ideas in the in the in the
product so if you were to sign a
thousand person company up
and only 100 people use it they only
bill you for 100. i love that as a user
but it does fly in the face of sort of
the best practice of everybody just
charging
however many number accounts that you
have not just the active ones in terms
of the winners
um you know congrats to stewart and the
founding team and the investors in slack
it's the end of a journey in a way
usually these companies
um are not destroyed anymore it used to
be when a company got bought you could
kind of flip a coin
it's the end of the brand like in the
yammer days which microsoft bought for a
billion and you don't hear anybody
talking about yammer usually the big
companies would screw up the
acquisitions
now they've gotten really good at it so
facebook left instagram alone
and youtube was kind of putting their
own building and left alone by google
you're starting to see this best
practice tableau has obviously done well
under salesforce where the big acquiring
company
lets the culture exist and doesn't break
the culture
doesn't break the momentum of the
company so i would assume that mark
benioff
is smart enough wise enough given his
knowledge of the history and the
industry and building such a
giant company that he knows not to screw
these things up so
it's kind of a bummer you know i think
that the company couldn't keep growing
and then use its public
stock to acquire other companies and it
does seem like there was some sort of a
product
roadblock inside the company where they
just couldn't get new features out
couldn't get
new competitive products in market to
get people excited they just
did a good job of being solid right
and there was no real competitor except
for microsoft teams to come out of this
hip chat gave up
and wound up selling to them so you have
to wonder is there going to be
a new chat enterprise software that
emerges now that salesforce has bought
this
i think you're going to see another
round of people looking and saying hmm
maybe now is a good time to launch a
competitor now you'd say why would that
be
very simple when these big companies
acquire them they get a bunch of
indigestion
right we talked about that like can they
acquire this without squashing it can
they acquire it
and accelerate its growth as opposed to
slow it down
who's going to run it do you have
somebody great is stewart going to stay
with the company or is
salesforce going to run it that's all
those are all the questions
that are going to come up it'll be the
second order questions if in fact
this deal goes through but either way
congratulations to all the
investors um for me it would be
disappointing if for example uber
were to sell as i'm still shareholder in
uber if they were to sell
you know to google or to you know
amazon i would feel good in a way but
you know because
it would be the end of the journey and
it would be an exit but i would also be
kind of bummed that they didn't keep
that independent spirit alive and become
a trillion dollar company eventually or
become you know a 500 billion dollar
company you really as an investor want
to see them
become independent concerns that exist
forever like
amazon and facebook and google have and
tesla has
tesla could have been taken out at 50
billion 75 billion by apple or google
but now at 500 billion or whatever their
market cap is they're going to be a
strong independent company for some time
to come
um so great job it's opportunistic right
you have these the stock market is on a
tear
but slack's stock has not gone up and
appreciated the way
other companies have so when they have
that funny money and you've got
a lot of equity that's why probably half
of this is cash is because the people
who are selling their shares in slack
if that report is in fact correct they
would like to cash in some chips
and get cash but they probably won't
have the upside of maybe
owning it now if salesforce stock goes
up 10
like amazon did after whole foods it
went up not 10
but the value of whole foods
theoretically on paper
benioff could get this for free if the
market cap goes up
25 billion dollars because people
believe that salesforce is a bigger
player and that this is a creative and
this is going to be a catalyst for
salesforce's existing products and that
salesforce's
existing team is going to be a catalyst
to drive more people to use slack and
adopt
it because it's more trusted in the
large enterprises
i wouldn't be surprised if salesforce
goes up 10 billion
20 billion dollars in the month after
this acquisition if it in fact occurs
because
that'd be a great sign that it was you
know a great acquisition and the market
believed it so we'll see it's a
bittersweet
bittersweet if true uh for the
shareholders i'm sure they would have
rather seen it become a large
independent company
and if you just think about like if
you're a slack user they have built in
audio and video
that hasn't changed and it's kind of
buried in the product and it hasn't
changed in
a year or two i haven't seen any new
features and i always thought to myself
why are people even
using zoom if they if they're using
slack because when you're in a slack
room you just
click start a call and you don't have to
install another piece of software you
don't have to leave that piece of
software you can use the same chat room
as opposed to firing up a second chat
room and i just think slack didn't do a
great job of marketing these products
to existing users i never got an upsell
inside of slack like hey
would you like to set up a call or you
know can you make a channel
that is a reoccurring weekly meeting so
let's say you had a weekly
wednesday staff meeting could you make a
room that was also the call
and have it be a calendar item you know
sort of thing it just didn't seem like
the product
vision it almost like it topped out
right and they didn't have somebody
there
making bold visionary bets which is
something that happened sort of with
twitter too they kind of just stagnated
and they couldn't get really great
products out there remember moments was
a bust
these fleets are a bust the audio is a
bust they screwed up vine
you can see when a company's product
team
is putting out stuff that doesn't work
and isn't refined
um or their product is just stagnant
that's when you know like these things
can occur and actually bettingoff was
in the running to possibly buy twitter
that was a really weird one remember
that he was thinking about buying
twitter so anyway he's an ambitious guy
he likes to buy things and build big
buildings good for
bending off i think this is gonna i
think it'll work out for them i think
they can get that 800
million dollars in revenue i think they
can 10x it over the next you know
couple years and if they do that's a
pretty good deal right get to five
billion ten million dollars i'm sure
there's five to ten million dollars in
revenue
left to unlock there and it would wind
up paying for itself okay
great job uh betting off sorry to
slack shareholders if this is in fact
the end of the road i would have liked
to see it going different direction and
we'll see you all next time bye-bye
this week in startups is brought to you
by our crowd helps you
invest early in pre-ipo companies
alongside professional vcs
if you're interested in investing you
can join our crowd for free
at our cia